melyek azok az alap
alapveszélyforrások amit láttok úgy
minden egyes közösségi médiában úgy
mintaként megismétlődni például egy
egyet mondok egy példát és lássam hogy
egyetértetek-e vele és akkor még
boncolgathatjuk számomra az egyik
legveszélyesebb dologz az hogy a
közösségi média megenged egy olyan
dolgot amit soha a világtörténelemben
nem engedett meg mégpedig az hogy
anonimok maradjunk tehát az az előző
közösségekben egy faluban vagy egy
városban mindig a nevünket az arcunkat
vállalnunk kellett nem kommentelhettünk
egy olyat amiután hogyha most látok
egy-egy olyan kommentet hogy ha azt
élőben történne meg akkor körülbelül fél
másodperc alatt kapn egy pofot érte de
az hogy anonimok maradjunk ez valami
természetellenes sosem voltunk anonimok
és és most először a a a úgy tudunk
kialakítani egy olyan képet magunkról
ami elfedi a valódi identitásunkat egy
hamis képet mutat hamis
identitással és akár több párhuzamos
ilyen identitásunk lehet amivel több
párhuzamos világot
tudunk élni egyszerre és több párhuzamos
mikroközösséghez tudunk tartozni